sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf
Sie recht herzlich zur Pressekonferenz
anlässlich den militärischen
Feierlichkeiten zum Nationalfeiertag
2021 begrüßen und bevor wir mit der
Pressekonferenz starten darf ich zu
einem Showact überleiten des showteams
der ersten klare Kompanie
[Musik]
nach diesen ersten Impressionen darf ich
unsere heutigen Redner an die Pulte
bieten ich darf recht herzlich begrüßen
die Frau Verteidigungsminister Claudia
Tanner
dem Militärkommandanten von Wien
Brigadier Kurt Wagner
und in Vertretung für den ORF Herren
kurz Pongratz
ich darf die Verteidigungsministerin um
ihre Worte bitten
sehr geehrter Herr Militärkommandant
sehr geehrter Herr Professor Pongratz
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren der
medienwerte anwesende ich glaube das war
ein besonderer Show Act der jetzt
abgeliefert worden ist von der Garde und
ich hoffe er animiert sehr viele ganz
nach dem Motto sei dabei mit uns
gemeinsam den 26 und virtuellen
Informations- und
Leistungsschau des Bundesheeres mit
dabei zu sein denn wir wollen Freunde
wir wollen begeisterte interessierte
aufmerksam machen gemeinsam aufmerksam
machen auf die Aufgaben auf die
Leistungen des österreichischen
Bundesheeres eine unlimitierte
Großveranstaltung wäre nicht das
richtige Zeichen aber wir wollen mit
einer wie schon letztes Jahr ganz
besonderen Hybriden Veranstaltung Jung
und Alt begeistern
unser Bundesheer war in Zusammenhang mit
der Pandemie unglaublich eingesetzt und
das ist noch immer so zu Spitzenzeiten
waren 8000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten im
Einsatz aber sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren die Pandemie das wird nicht die
letzte Bedrohung sein mit der wir uns in
Österreich ein Europa auf der ganzen
Welt beschäftigen werden müssen denn
eines ist sicher die Sicherheitslage in
Europa die wird sich nicht verbessern
die Herausforderungen die werden steigen
das zeigt uns das risikobild unserer
Expertinnen und Experten die gute
Nachricht ist aber wir können uns
vorbereiten wir wissen einigermaßen gut
worauf wir uns vorbereiten müssen da
meine ich die Herausforderungen und
Szenarien des 21 jahrhunderts wie
Terrorismus Cyber-Attacken
Naturkatastrophen Blackouts und
Pandemien
gerade Naturkatastrophen mit ihren
Folgen und den dementsprechenden
Einsätzen unseres Heeres haben wir in
den vergangenen Jahren und Jahrzehnten
zur Genüge erlebt und wahrscheinlich
werden sie durch den Klimawandel noch
weiter zunehmen aber sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren wer von uns hätte jemals
gedacht dass es zu einer Pandemie kommt
die auch Österreich erfasst doch ist es
passiert wer hätte einen
terroranschlager gedacht wir vor mitten
in Wien wir vor einem Jahr passiert ist
und doch hat dieser Albtraum
stattgefunden und wer hätte vor ein paar
Jahren noch einen Blackout gedacht
unsere Experten sagen aber innerhalb der
nächsten Jahre wird uns das Treffen das
ist ein Einsatz realistisches Szenario
denn ein Europa weiter Strom
Infrastruktur und
versorgungsausfall der kann immer
möglich sein was heißt das dann das
heißt es gibt kein Licht kein Handy kein
Internet keinen funktionieren Bankomaten
keine Heizung keine Tankstelle keine
Straßenbahnen keine funktionierende
Ampel und unsere Aufgabe als
österreichisches Bundesheer ist es in so
einem Fall die Führungsfähigkeit der
Republik zu unterstützen und im
Katastrophenfall auch den anderen
Einsatzorganisationen als strategische
Reserve helfen zu können
ja und genau aus diesen Gründen
veranstalten wir jährlich und das schon
seit 26 Jahren die Leistungsschau am
Nationalfeiertag um Ihnen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren zu zeigen was unser
Bundesheer alles kann was unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten tagtäglich für
den Schutz unseres Landes und für uns
rund um die Uhr leisten ja und auch
heuer haben wir uns für die
Leistungsschau etwas Besonderes
einfallen lassen unter dem Motto wir
schützen Österreich sei dabei alle
Aktivitäten und Maßnahmen rund um den
Nationalfeiertag 2021 erlebbar zu machen
wir laden die Österreicherinnen und
Österreich auf allen
Kommunikationskanälen dazu ein in eine
Rolle und Funktion eines Soldaten einer
Soldatin zu schlüpfen und so in seine
spannende vielfältige Arbeitswelt
einzutauchen das könnten wir nicht ohne
unsere Partner ohne dem or das könnten
wir nicht ohne dass Militärkommando Wien
wir laden Sie ein virtuell
beizuwohnen unter
www.nationalfeiertag.21.at diese
Leistungsschau steht Ihnen ab sofort
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren bis
einschließlich 27 Oktober zur Verfügung
sie bietet in einer 360 Grad Ansicht
denn Programm mit zahlreichen Highlights
dort können Sie sich ein Bild vom
vielfältigen Einsatzspektrum unserer
Soldatinnen und Soldaten machen und das
wohl ein besonderes Highlight dieser
virtuellen Leistungsschau ist dass all
jene die die Leistung scharf online
miterleben sich
erstmalig ein rundumwelt eines
Eurofighter machen können wir laden Sie
ein am Kopf mit Platz zu nehmen und
unsere Luftstreitkräfte aus einer ganz
anderen Perspektive erleben zu können
da virtuelle Heldenplatz sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren bittet aber nicht nur
die Möglichkeit sich über das
Einsatzspektrum das große
einsatzrechnung des Bundesheeres zu
informieren sondern sie können nach
einzelnen Missionen interaktiv selbst
miterleben es gibt fünf Actionfilme in
fünf Missionen dabei kann jede und jeder
ein persönliches Profilbild hochladen
und Teil dieser Mission sein wer das
Video dann unter dem Hashtag Bundesheer
auch noch auf den Social Media Kanälen
postet der nimmt bei unserem Gewinnspiel
teil und kann bis 27 Oktober wirklich
großartige Preise gewinnen insgesamt
verlosen wir 500 Preise an die
Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer
traditionell bleibt jedenfalls unsere
Angelobung am 26 Oktober es werden heuer
100 Rekruten am Heldenplatz angelobt
auch das wird wie letztes Jahr live
übertragen werden und diese haben
anschließend eine ganz besondere Aufgabe
sie werden für die nächsten vier Monate
die Ehrenkompanie der Garde sein vielen
Dank an dieser Stelle auch dem ORF der
uns unterstützt mit einer
Live-Berichterstattung zum
Nationalfeiertag dazu wird Ihnen Herr
Professor Kurt Pongratz bekannter Chef
Regisseur beim ORF sicher noch mehr
sagen ich bin überzeugt davon dass wir
mit diesem Programm in Hybride Form der
Veranstaltung den virtuellen Heldenplatz
der mehr als dreistündigen
Liveberichterstattung des ORF ein ganz
besonderes Live-Gefühl erzeugen können
und dieses auch in Österreichs
Wohnzimmer
können wir freuen uns auf eine spannende
auf eine interessante Veranstaltung und
ich hoffe dass sie alle vor dem
Bildschirmen live dabei sein werden
vielen Dank
ich darf nun den Militärkommandanten von
Wien Herrn Brigadier Kurt Wagner und
seine Worte suchen
sehr geehrte Frau bundesmeisterin
Professor auch wenn es nicht so gern
hören
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
wie üblich darf ich sie als
Militärkommandant von Wien in die
Details des offiziellen Programmes hier
am Nationalfeiertag informieren um 9 Uhr
erfolgt die ganze Überlegung durch den
Herrn Bundespräsidenten im weiraum am
äußeren Burgtor um 10 Uhr schließt die
grenzüberlegung der Bundesregierung an
und um 11 Uhr wie bereits angesprochen
erfolgte feierliche Angelobung von 100
Rekruten der Garde diese Rekruten
stammen aus fast allen Bundesländern
zwei Drittel von ihnen stammen aus Wien
sie sind Anfang September bei der Karte
eingerückt haben jetzt den ersten Teil
ihrer Ausbildung in Horn abgeschlossen
und werden weiter ausgebildet
zukünftig werden sie auch
bei offiziellen Anlässen wie
Staatsbesuchen oder militärischen
Festveranstaltungen die ehrenkomponie im
Rahmen einer Ehrenformation der Garten
nach der Angelobung erfolgen ein
Überflug von zwei Eurofightern und einer
Herkules und der Absprung von vier
Fallschirmspringen vom ja Kommando und
ihrer Landung hier am Heldenplatz werden
das Programm hier am Heldenplatz finden
die Corona bedingt nicht mögliche
Leistungsschau analog am Heldenplatz
wird ja virtuell durchgeführt wie das
die Frau Bundesministerin bereits
vorgestellt hat
selbstverständlich werden wir in
Absprache mit der Stadt Wien
die gültigen corona-bestimmungen
einhalten deshalb erfolgt die Angelobung
auch nur von einer begrenzten Anzahl
nämlich 100 Soldaten es sind dann nur
mit Einladungen auch Angehörige und eine
überschaubare Anzahl an Ehrengästen hier
möglich für alle anderen Interessierten
kommt eben der Nationalfeiertag und
Informations- und Leistungsschau zu
ändern nach Hause im Fernsehen oder im
Livestream ich darf die Bevölkerung
daher auch heuer wieder ersuchen nicht
auf den Heldenplatz zu kommen sondern
dass virtuelle Angebot zu nutzen vielen
Dank
ich darf nun den Vertreter des ORF Herrn
Kurt Pongratz um seine Worte aussuchen
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin sehr
geehrter Herr Feger dir meine Damen und
Herren erlauben Sie mir zunächst
herzliche Grüße von generaldirekt zu
übermitteln der leider verhindert ist
und aus diesem Grund darf ich dann ein
paar Informationen
über den Nationalfeiertag 2021 im ORF
und im Speziellen für die
Live-Übertragung der Feierlichkeiten am
Heldenplatz geben vorher ein paar
Eckdaten zur letztjährigen Sendung 2020
durchschnittlich
36.000 Zuschauer erreichte die
Übertragung im letzten Jahr das bedeutet
einen enormen durchschnittlichen
Marktanteil von 33%
und das an einem Feiertags Vormittag
historisch war es die erfolgreichste
Sendung die jemals nach der Zip um neuen
gesendet wurde besonders erfreulich in
diesem Zusammenhang ist der Anteil der
jüngeren Zielgruppe 12 bis 29 Jahre mit
einem Marktanteil von 25 Prozent das
Interesse an dieser Feierlichkeit war
also extrem groß und natürlich weiß
keine Frage für Channel Manager
Alexander Hofer auch heuer den
rot-weiß-roten Fernsehtag wieder mit dem
Event am Heldenplatz zu beginnen im
Hauptabend wird ORF 2 das
Erfolgsprogramm neun Plätze 9 Schätze
senden und daran anschließend die
Produktion Heimat großer Töchter und
Söhne Porträts von sehr engagierten
erfolgreichen aber großteils unbekannter
Menschen den Abschluss des
ausschließlich österreichischen
Fernsehabends bildet dann die Ehrung
Austria 21 die Österreicherinnen und
Österreicher des Jahres 2021
nun zum Heurigen Event am Heldenplatz
wir werden mit 12 Kameras übertragen und
haben drei steadycams einen
teleskopierbaren Kran und einen Kran mit
50 Meter Ausleger im Einsatz um die
gesamte Szenerie am Heldenplatz
einfangen zu können wie bereits im
Vorjahr wird es eine Helmkamera für
einen Fallschirmspringer geben der ja
hier landen wird und erstmalig werden
wir auch versuchen eine Schaltung in das
Cockpit eines eurofight-fighters zu
machen
dies auch als kleine Absicherung im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr da waren alle
Kameras bereits in Position um einen
spektakulären Überflug über den
Heldenplatz in die Wohnzimmer
Österreichs zu senden aber das Wetter
hatte uns einen Strich durch die
Rechnung gemacht und man hat nur den
ohrenbetäubenden düsenschall gehört aber
keinen einzigen Eurofighter gesehen
die Wolkendecke über Wien war zu dicht
heuer allerdings wurde uns versichert
von Seiten des Bundesheers dass die Jets
bereits im Raum St Pölten unter die
Wolkendecke tauchen können und dann
am Heldenplatz auftauchen werden in
sichtbarer Höhe
das ist die eine Versicherung die zweite
Versicherung ist dass die ORF
Wetterredaktion uns versichert hat dass
an diesem Tag schön Wetter herrscht
wolkenloser Himmel und das klingt
besonders erfolgversprechend die
Sondersendung der Nationalfeiertag die
unmittelbar nach der zieht um 9 Uhr
wieder beginnt wird von Rebecca Salzer
im Studium Küniglberg moderiert ihr zur
Seite stehen in bewährterweise
innenpolitikschef Hans Bürger und
seitens des Bundesheeres general major
Bruno Günther Hofbauer am Heldenplatz
selbst werden mehrereporter und
Reporterinnen die grenzniederlegung und
die Angelobung der Rekruten begleiten
außerdem wurde dem ORF gestartet aus dem
sonderministerrat im Bundeskanzleramt
live zu berichten und abschließenden
Frau Ministerin und Herr Brigadier Alarm
sie mir noch ein Wort zur Zusammenarbeit
österreichisches Bundesheer und ORF
bereits im Vorjahr gab es keine
besonderen Schwierigkeiten und unlösbare
Probleme wenngleich viele der handelte
Personen auf beiden Seiten sich erst
näher lernen mussten und auch die
speziell Notwendigkeiten einer
Live-Übertragung dieser Dimension für
beide Bereiche Bundesheer und ORF erster
arbeitet werden mussten aber in diesem
Jahr war die Kooperation einfach perfekt
und friktionsfrei weil man vieles gar
nicht mehr erklären und thematisieren
musste und das gegenseitige Vertrauen
die Vorarbeiten extrem erleichtert hat
und dafür möchte ich mich auch im Namen
von unserem sendeverantwortlichen
Redakteur Fritz jungmeier bei allen
Damen und Herren des Bundesheeres recht
herzlich bedanken wir freuen uns auf
einen informativen erfolgreichen und
würdevoll Nationalfeiertag 2021 vielen
Dank
ich darf mich für diese Ausführungen
bedanken und darf nun an die
medienvertreterinnen und Media
Vertretern ersuchen sich per Handzeichen
zu melden es kommt wer zu Ihnen dass Sie
sich zuerst bitte mit dem Medium melden
und dann die Frage stellen ja also
Kramer Puls 24 Frau
Verteidigungsministerin mittlerweile
sind viele Leute geimpft es gibt bei
Großveranstaltungen manchmal drei g2g
warum hat man sich dagegen entschieden
unter solchen Umständen dann doch eine
Leistung schaut zu machen und hat die
ganz ins Internet und ins Fernsehen
verlegt
ja vielen Dank für diese Frage die sich
so beantworten lässt das seine
Veranstaltung in dieser Größenordnungen
sehr langen
Zeitablauf auch braucht das ist der eine
Punkt und zum damaligen Zeitpunkt wo die
Planungen begonnen haben man natürlich
auf die Sicherheit und auf die
corona-lage so wie sie vorausgesagt war
zweitens der Experten auch Rücksicht
nehmen musste der zweite Punkt ist der
den der Herr schäfriseur angesprochen
hat wir haben mit der vorjährigen
Hybriden Veranstaltungen eine
unglaubliche
Reichweite gehabt wenn man sich
vorstellt wie erfolgreichste Sendung die
über ein drittelacher erreicht dann ist
das schon ein Format dass wir auch in
Zukunft eben fortsetzen wollen der
dritte Punkt ist es findet ja mehr statt
als es voriges Jahr der Fall war wenn
man daran denkt die Angelobung der
Rekruten das war zum vorjährigen
Zeitpunkt 12 zum Heurigen Zeitpunkt
werden es 100 sein inklusive dann auch
der Angehörigen auch hier sieht man sehr
wohl einen einen Fortschritt und der
dritte Punkt ist dass wir diese Form der
hybriden Veranstaltung das heißt immer
mehr hier vor Ort zu machen wenn es die
Situation erlaubt aber kombiniert
insbesondere auch für das Ziel Publikum
der jüngeren das sind auch diejenigen
die wir es auch schon gefallen ja
durchaus ansprechen wollen beibehalten
werden und von den leistungsschauern her
sind wir nicht zuletzt in der
ausmusterungswoche wer von ihnen das
vielleicht mitverfolgt hat an der
Militärakademie wo es auch schon eine
große Vorort Leistungsschau gegeben hat
die ebenfalls übertragen worden ist
schon in diese Richtung gegangen das
heißt wir wollen auch in Zukunft
jedenfall diesen Anteil da online der
hybriden Veranstaltung so viel wie eben
möglich ist an diesem Ort beibehalten
gibt es weitere Fragen
Alexandra Nindl ATV aktuell angesichts
der aktuellen innenpolitischen Situation
würde ich sie gerne um einen Kommentar
bieten weil mich die ÖVP ja in den
letzten Umfragen doch ordentlich
abgerutscht ist und mit der SPÖ
teilweise gleich auf ist
das was die Österreicherinnen und
Österreicher sich zu Recht erwarten ist
dass wir unsere Arbeit machen als
Bundesregierung das ist auch meine
Aufgabe als Verteidigungsministerin dies
zu tun das machen wir indem wir intensiv
daran arbeiten an einem würdigen
würdevollen Nationalfeiertag das ist das
heutige Thema es gibt aber auch sonst
genug zu tun wenn wir merken dass wir im
Bereich und das ist ja angesprochen
worden der Pandemie was die
Impfbereitschaft anbelangt noch einiges
zu tun haben gemeinsam ist das der eine
Bereich wenn wir daran denken dass auch
wirtschaftlich und was die
Arbeitslosigkeit anbelangt noch einiges
zu tun ist dann ist das mit Sicherheit
der zweite Bereich die Österreicherinnen
und Österreicher erwarten sich dass wir
arbeiten und das tun wir auch was die
Vorgänge anbelangt die Sie angesprochen
haben bin ich davon überzeugt dass die
Justiz am Wort ist und dass das im
Endeffekt auch zu einer Klärung und das
ist ja auch die Aufgabe der Justiz der
Vorwürfe führen wird
gibt es weitere Fragen zu den
militärischen Feierlichkeiten und
Nationalfeiertag
wenn nicht dann bedanke ich mich recht
herzlich und darf damit die
Pressekonferenz beenden danke